Welcome to the Meta Store.
It wasn't a huge crowd waiting for the opening of Meta's first physical store.
Still, the enthusiasm was there.
The store is just a stone throw away from the labs developing Meta's virtual reality...
...and augmented reality hardware...
...while showcasing their latest products.
In our store, you'll be able to experience Quest 2, Portal and Ray-Ban stories.
Facebook's parent company intends to examine customers' reactions and expectations.
Meta and its competitors have invested massively in virtual reality hardware,...
...hoping to diversify beyond ads on its sites and apps,...
...which accounted for more than 97% of its revenues in the latest quarter.
The virtual and augmented reality market...
...is expected to hit an annual 500 billion dollars in coming years.
Meta is prepared to lose some 10 billion dollars this year in its Reality Labs...
...to develop that future.